we've been sort of wandering speculating
increasingly concerned about Donald
Trump's inaction around Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico has been totally devastated
by multiple hurricanes nope our little
water very few supplies and only
recently has Donald Trump actually
started to really appear to act like he
knows Puerto Rico is part of the United
States after all and that Puerto Ricans
are American citizens just like anybody
else and I've been sort of mentioning
this off and on for a while I actually
tweeted about it yesterday where I said
quote quoting myself like I've said
Donald Trump probably didn't realize
Puerto Ricans were US citizens now that
someone told him he's tweeting about it
and interestingly enough there's a whole
bunch of new angles on this the first
being that there's a poll which points
out it is very common that Americans not
just Trump don't know that Puerto Ricans
are American citizens there's a new poll
by morning consult which surveyed 2,200
adults and it shows that only 54% of
Americans barely half of Americans know
that if you're born in Puerto Rico you
are an American citizen now if you think
Puerto Ricans are quote foreigners you
consider the hurricane disaster in
Puerto Rico a foreign disaster not a
domestic disaster now you could debate
whether we should pay less attention to
foreign disasters but there's no doubt
that if you see something as a foreign
disaster it's different in your mind
than if you see it as a domestic
disaster if you split up these poll
results by age group the numbers are
even worse if you look just at Americans
18 to 29 years old only 37% of that age
group 18 to 29 realizes that Puerto
Ricans are citizens and Hillary Clinton
interestingly enough is wondering about
the exact same thing at least when it
comes to Trump she said in an interview
a couple of days ago she's not sure
Trump is aware of the fact that Puerto
Ricans are citizens of the United States
I would love it if Trump demanded the
resignation of the President of Puerto
Rico over their terrible hurricane
response I genuinely don't know that he
knew they were citizens before
he told him likely over the last three
or four days I don't think he knew that
Guam was the US territory before North
Korea started threatening them with
nuclear weapons yeah I would not be
surprised about that either
and as it turns out not that surprising
those who know Puerto Ricans are
American citizens are way more likely to
support giving aid to Puerto Rican
citizens who are of course American
citizens if you look at how likely one
is to support aid for Puerto Rico if you
know that Puerto Ricans are American
citizens you're 81 percent of that group
says yes
let's give aid to Puerto Rico if you
don't know that
Puerto Ricans are American citizens
you're about half as likely to support
aid for Puerto Rico now it is true even
though Puerto Ricans are American
citizens they can't vote for the
president in the general election could
it be that Trump is actually brilliant
and he knows that Puerto Ricans are
American citizens look at that look at
the standard for brilliance for the
president now just knowing that Puerto
Ricans are American citizens and he
doesn't care because they can't vote in
the general election Trump at his next
speech Porto Ricans are Americans did
you know that most people didn't know
that that's code whenever Trump says in
his speeches did you know that most
people didn't know what he means is I
only learned this three minutes before
coming onstage yeah he does that pretty
frequently doesn't mean I think it's
completely sound at least to oppose Pro
Rican statehood because they're not
economically viable I guess you know the
debt crisis is a big deal right now and
you know a lot of Republicans are gonna
be opposed to it too because that means
more Democratic representation but to
just I think that they're not part of
the United States
that's just unreasonable it's not how it
is yeah and and what's kind of funny is
Trump is partially responsible for at
least a little bit of the debt that
Puerto Rico's in Trump has some horrible
backstory I don't even remember the
details some kind of default or
non-payment of something with a failed
Trump property in Puerto Rico and and so
Trump and some of his cronies are part
of the problem and then they say hey
well listen look at the Puerto Rican
economic situation that's why we
shouldn't really consider making them
states because there'll be a drag on our
economy of course what's funny about
that is that red states many red states
in the United States are subsidized by
money that comes from blue
States but you don't see anybody saying
we'll kick them out of the union right
talk about the makers and the takers
yeah that that it says it says a lot
about that phrase for sure we have to
think about education as a national
security issue
right I mean ignorant is why people
support bad policy in this case the
numbers are clear you don't realize an
undeniable fact which is Puerto Ricans
or American citizens you are less likely
to be in favor of supporting Puerto
Ricans and Puerto Rico in this natural
disaster recovery effort ignorant is why
people support bad policy in many cases
we often ignore it when our officials
are passing bad policy because we're not
even aware of what they're doing or we
end up acquiescing to it and this and
climate change poles and so many other
polls show us that ignorance is a
national security issue and we're seeing
it here with Puerto Rico front and
center send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show